[Musique]
c'est l'association saint paul en 10
sport propose depuis un an personnes
porteuses de handicap des sorties sur
les sentiers réunionnais grâce à un
matériel inédit sur l'île des fauteuils
électriques tout terrain donc c'est un
véhicule qui est adapté au tout terrain
dont il ya quatre suspensions
indépendantes
il ya deux moteurs électriques dans les
roues arrière donc un des modèles à des
freins quatre freins à disque puisque
celui là se mais quand on coupe
l'accélération reste en roue libre et
l'autre modèle l'una fonctionne
uniquement sur les deux moteurs
électriques ils assurent les roues
arrière donc ça fonctionne comme un
moteur et une fauteuil électrique
normale dire que quand on arrive
d'accélération le moteur s'arrête
afin de permettre à tous de pouvoir se
promener au coeur des plus belles forêts
de l'île low nf en partenariat avec le
département a adhéré au projet en
ouvrant à cette activité cinq pistes
forestières
ce sont des députés des pistes
forestières en terre comme toute piste
forestière avec quelques quelques
cailloux mais qui n'ont pas nécessité de
gros travaux la structure était en place
les moyens je parlais des véhicules des
fauteuils électriques étaient totalement
adapté et il n'y avait aucun problème
pour que l'activité puisse se mettre en
se mettre en place c'est important
pourquoi parce que nous sommes
propriétaires donc de vous des forêts
départementaux domaniale et c'est vrai
qu'il faut arriver à ouvrir ces espaces
à l'ensemble du public et plus encore
aux personnes à mobilité réduite
c'est une priorité pour nous on parle
d'épanouissement main et je pense que
rendre accessibles ces espaces c'est
aussi rendre service aux gens pour
qu'ils puissent s'épanouir dans ces
milieux naturels
un projet qui permet aux personnes en
situation de handicap de découvrir des
sites inaccessibles à leur fauteuil
roulant c'est notamment
grande re découverte un grand plaisir de
pouvoir passer au delà de la frustration
de voir la nature de loin sa maman à
voilà soulagement une grand plaisir tout
simplement se retrouver dans la nature
de pouvoir se déplacer ses déplacements
soient sans grand problème madelin
l'association propose des sorties d'une
à trois heures sur cinq pistes
forestières de l'île d'ô volcan de au
maïdo et une à saint paul
[Musique]